[Music]
appearance
welcome to Alabama's makers of five ones
since 382 BC I am the one keeper and you
were all here to witness a warning I
don't know if you felt it but when the
door opened just then I felt a strong
surge of magic in this room we have some
very powerful witches and wizards in
this room and a few mothers as well this
powers very strange it's been bouncing
around the room since you walked in the
door it's like a Quidditch match
it's coming from back here
how do you know him speak he's your
brother
yeah that's why it's been bouncing back
and forth across the both of you have
you do headlong I broke mine anyone want
to talk to you
you still covered well a broken wand
means a new wand is available to use
which would you like to come and have a
parent what is your name I'm at m-80s
weird name Oh
step to the light every of that the one
is this is the core of a powerful
magical substance use unicorn has
Phoenix tail feathers and the
heartstrings and Dragons know to Allah
better ones of the same just as don't
you Phoenix and so mad let's try to find
[Music]
they run from the room
yes
16:02 smiling alright let's see let's do
something very clips you see this matter
hmm
I used to started to get to all of the
shells in this room but I move it using
my from here right to there okay all
right it's very simple just a few feet
yes and then I use the spell
Akio nether Akio letter you know it's
always been quite clear to those of us
who study one more the best results
always seem to come all right
[Music]
I wonder I have been saving this one
many years just waiting
[Music]
when you go through the doorway perhaps
you do like maths we'll find the one
that you choose thank you for shopping
at other vendors enjoy